stop me if you've heard this before hey
I just found this amazing show you just
gotta get through the first bunch of
episodes to get to the good stuff
needless to say I've been there and it's
been the reason I've watched tons of
shows I never enjoyed well into the
story I'm talking like 35 episodes in
some cases but I otherwise would have
dropped after the first or second
episodes and no one instilled this
mantra in me that I for some reason have
to keep watching until it gets to the
good part in the era of Netflix
originals Hollywood blockbusters YouTube
Brad and HBO specials this notion is
even more pervasive than it ever has
been that in order to give a show a fair
shot you're encouraged to in some cases
what a significant chunk of the TV show
or film in order to truly decide whether
or not you actually like or dislike it
and to that I say oh god I've genuinely
never understood this point of view the
notion that I am somehow being unfair to
the creative process or artistic merit
of a given piece of media because I
don't force myself through the
mediocrity in order to get to something
worthwhile is it best misguided and at
worst damaging to future generations
perception of the creative process so
today I want to explain to you why the
first act of a film or the first episode
of a TV show is vital in other words
today I am going to explain how
important the first 20 minutes really is
or should be as I'm sure many of you
have already noticed the first 20
minutes is about enough time for the
first act of your story and about as
long as the first episode of a typical
televised production this isn't by
accident the job of this opening 20
minutes worth of scenes is to introduce
us all to the plot setting themes and
characters of the story so what makes
for a great scene
well Robert McKee describes a scene as
being a story in miniature
no matter locations or length a scene is
unified around desire action conflict
and change in other words a scene can be
broken down like a movie can meaning if
we assume a film is driven by character
like a lot of superhero films are
ideally within the first 20 minutes of
that story we should expect these scenes
that make up that run time to tell us
about who the characters are and more
importantly who the superhero is and if
they don't achieve what they're trying
to do then the viewer will lose interest
and I just so happy
to have the best comparison to help us
better understand this concept I'm going
to compare the flower shop seen from
Tommy Wiseau's the room to the sandwich
shop seen from spider-man homecoming I
know how this looks but stay with me
here these scenes have tons in common
they're both roughly the same length
being less than 1 minute long involved
the same number of characters try to
achieve the same effects narrative li
and feature cuddles with a cute pet
let's begin desire there's a brief
establishing shot of the setting and
building Peter is going into it's a
sandwich shop he must want a sandwich
just a guess
action Peter greets the store owner
casually and makes an unconventional
sandwich request conflict the sandwich
clerk playfully makes a comment about
peter's aunt in spanish under the
assumption that peter can't understand
him peter then reveals that he
understood the comment by making an
equally inappropriate pass at his
daughter in spanish the clerk taken
aback by this request $10 for the
sandwich as recompense peter insists
that he's joking and handsome $5 the
original price change Peter received
sandwich however now the clerk is aware
that he speaks Spanish and knows not to
make a pass at his hunt and he pets the
cat in less than a minute we learned the
nature of Peters relationship with the
store owner were shown how smart Peter
is and what he's like when faced with
consequences and that's not even the end
of this scenes utility within the entire
film in one of the first action scenes
of the movie Peter saves both this store
owner and his cat from a fire that scene
would not have worked if not for this
one
the save however cannot be said for
Tommy Wiseau's the room with that said I
have seen the room seven times and
spider-man homecoming only three so
there's something to be said about the
bizarre train wreck that is Tommy's
magnum opus while this scene has very
similar composition to spider-man's one
it fails and satisfying this principal
the desire and action is covered but
there is ZERO conflict where homecoming
initiated a small argument between the
store owner and Peter to demonstrate
aspects of their relationship the room
just straight-up tells us additionally
despite being roughly the same length
with the same moving parts while trying
to achieve the same thing within the
story it's sort of unfair to compare
these two because the room spends 62
percent of the scenes showing Johnny
arriving and leave
in his car you have Tammy part Lisa
despite keeping this concept of scene
structure in mind however it's still
possible to dislike the first episode
for a number of reasons perhaps it
starts off slow so what keeps the pace
up in a story
well John York says a writer's task is
to distill the story they're telling by
choosing to focus on the important or
significant moments out of less they
will attempt to capture a whole and
presented this specific principle of
storytelling outlines why we don't need
to see a character doing mundane tasks
and why I can't stand listening to my
uncle tell stories the fella the very
first scene of a TV show
comic our films should be significant
and the ideal launching off point for
the story to establish its premise if
the viewer gets the right impression of
what a film is about then they can
decide whether or not they will be
invested long-term or just drop the
story entirely but what's a premise well
a premise is the story stated in one
sentence it is the simplest combination
of character and plot and typically
consists of some event that starts the
action and so in a way it's fair to
expect the first episode or the
beginning of a film to communicate its
premise to show us what we should come
to expect from it the first episode of
attack on Titan shows the walls falling
and the main characters life in ruin
after in no uncertain terms if this
episode doesn't catch your interest then
you won't enjoy the story that follows
nearly as much as those that did enjoy
it the first episode of The Walking Dead
demonstrates the main character
navigating the post-apocalyptic world
infested with zombies in this first
episode it establishes the character
setting and premise of the entire story
if you don't like this first episode of
this series then you're in for a rough
ride because it's more of this this is
the benefit of a story starting honestly
and strong the first episode of Pokemon
friends one punch man my hero academia
and many others demonstrate exactly in
no uncertain terms what their shows are
like right away and I think it's fair to
say that if you don't enjoy any of these
first episodes then you probably won't
get anything out of the rest of it
orally
not to the same degree others who loved
it might expect you to even YouTube
videos to a certain extent despite their
comparatively shorter length tried to
start strong and established themselves
early take a channel like film theory as
a prime example of this every single
episode on that channel begins with a
stinger something that gives the viewer
a taste of what's to come later on one
that demonstrates the visual style and
the humor more often than not of the
media to follow not to mention the topic
this isn't by accident and it's a style
adopted from traditional storytelling in
films and television ensuring that the
first 20 minutes is representative of
what follows is vital even if it
technically breaks other story
conventions to achieve this desired
effect for instance one of the many
lessons to be gleaned from my comparison
of the rooms flower shop scene and the
sandwich shop scene from spider-man
homecoming is that if the scene doesn't
serve the story then it can be cut right
it stands to reason that if you're
telling a story you should only expand
upon the aspects that concern the story
in the most efficient manner possible
however we have plenty of examples where
that isn't the case at all one obvious
example of this can be seen during
Indiana Jones's Raiders of the Lost Ark
when you think about that films
beginning of the story you think of this
scene naturally I mean it's possibly the
most memorable moment of the entire film
however that isn't the beginning of the
story at all this is the second scene we
are introduced to certain characters yes
that play a role in the story later on
but none of the activity that takes
place here plays a role in how the story
progresses thereafter remove this iconic
first scene and the story will still
make just as much sense as it did before
so why include it well because it
represents what's to come much more
accurately than this scene does despite
that scene directly beginning the story
it essentially all depends on what
aspect of the story you deemed to be
more important the plot setting theme or
character and honestly that's the crux
of all of this what you as an individual
deemed to be entertaining or interesting
could be unique
you I happen to think that shows like
Death Note an attack on Titan are some
of the most captivating and entertaining
productions out there however that's
because I happen to hold plot in very
high regard if someone else were to look
at attack on Titan and their primary
focus was say character they might not
like it as much as myself and that's
totally fine TV shows comics and films
are artistic expression of a given
artist a person the same way one person
cannot guarantee that every single
person on the planet will like them an
artist can't guarantee that their show
no matter how well-written
or how captivating will entertain
everyone if the opening episode or if
you're being generous episodes of a show
are not capturing your interest then in
all likelihood the show might just not
be for you and much like alcohol forcing
yourself to drink it until you acquire a
taste for it is at least for me a bit
excessive the entire purpose of the
first twenty minutes of any story is to
give you a taste to give you an idea of
the direction the story is moving in to
introduce you to the individuals that
will accompany you on this journey and
so if you don't enjoy the company aren't
happy with the direction or maybe the
story just isn't capturing your
imagination that should be enough of an
indication for you and that friend that
keeps pestering you that this story just
isn't your speed and that's what the
first episode is designed for it shows
you what the story can become how sad
how inspirational and how captivating it
can be to you specifically and thus that
is how powerful that is how impactful
and that is how important the first 20
minutes of any story really is
thanks for watching
[Music]
you